y austeridad para conjurar la crisis la
nueva ministra de economía argentina
silvana batakis anunció su plan para
controlar la espiral inflacionaria la
caída de los mercados y la creciente
presión sobre el peso además reiteró que
cumplirá con el acuerdo firmado en marzo
por el presidente alberto fernández para
refinanciar la deuda de 44 mil millones
de dólares con el fondo monetario
internacional que nosotros no vamos a
gastar más de lo que tenemos se
mantienen las metas acordadas con el
fondo monetario internacional si esto
también es muy importante nosotros ya
mantuvimos reuniones con las máximas
autoridades con kristalina georgieva y
también reuniones acá en argentina con
el representante del fondo monetario
para nuestro país y entendemos que es un
acuerdo que firmamos como estado y que
nosotros tenemos que cumplir el manejo
económico ha causado divisiones entre el
oficialismo dividido entre el presidente
alberto fernández y la poderosa
vicepresidenta cristina fernández las
discusiones internas del gobierno se
centran en cómo enfrentar la inflación
del 65 por ciento anual
las mayores del mundo y la caída del
poder adquisitivo en las calles cientos
de opositores salieron para protestar
contra las medidas del gobierno
la designación de la nueva ministra
muestra que cambian de figurita pero no
cambia el rumbo económico que estoy
atado al de gmail por esto creemos que
es necesario decidir que lo que hace
falta es cambiar justamente ese rumbo
pueden cambiar vamos a ir pagando
el país sudamericano uno de los
principales exportadores de cereales
enfrenta a una subida extrema del dólar
agravado por el aumento de precios de
las importaciones de energía que ha
ocasionado además que las reservas
internacionales del país disminuyan lo
que profundiza aún más la crisis de
argentina